ah how's it going bros my name is peter
pan today we're playing a very special
game it's called inside you may not have
heard of it but it's made by play day
the people who made limbo limbo is one
of my favorite indie games of all time
it is such a fantastic indie game if you
haven't checked it out go check it out
right now do it inside is not even out
outside yet
inside is not even out yet for some
reason I'm allowed to play this game for
you breast this is gonna be an epic play
- I'm so excited the game looks
fantastic have I hyped it up enough for
you yet let's just play it play Dead's
inside already we got color which is
what we didn't have in limbo I can't
tell what is happening oh there we are
we're playing as a little dude again I'm
controlling this okay let's walk through
the forest I can jump what else can I do
I don't know I love to jump animation
it's so smooth it's so pretty
so limbo was an amazing 2d platformer
I guess isometric platformer is that
what it's called
2d isometric 2d no one cares um and
they're doing the same thing here it had
a really cool story as well even though
it didn't really tell it too much thanks
pal I expect the same with this oh my
god what is this
okay looks like we're sneaking now it's
someone after us maybe seems like it to
be escaped or something
this is so it so immersive I love it
okay let's keep sneaking around out
there's more guards are they hurt us oh
my god they're wearing masks oh my god
what a way to start a game looks like
our chance to move what is that thing I
can't control the camera angle
whatsoever and this is the refrigerator
from Indiana Jones what oh there's a
truck again can we climb this perhaps we
can move the refrigerator though that's
what I imagined we would do yes would be
okay some of the puzzles in limbo I will
talk about limbo a lot I'm sorry
ah broke my legs we're really tricky
like I would really have to sit down and
think about it so hopefully this won't
be too painful when other people
watching be like oh my god it's so
obvious why does he not solve the
puzzle I know you guys play now
I know how you think all right
not as Club ah god dammit
could've warned me about that
well maybe if you didn't run in a
straight line you would get away from
these people oh we need we need to jump
from here maybe yeah no all right I'm
already stuck
okay let's go back and see if there's
something we need this box perhaps hey
you come with me mr. box could be a
missus I wouldn't know
oh my god ah is that supposed to how do
I do it
you would die a lot in limbo as well I
wonder if that's the case in this game
let's be careful here what is that it
looks like a prison or something doesn't
it
so Michael has already finished the game
wells man and he's oh my god they see me
oh no the dark holy that was scary
that was so close oh my god
oh god they know we're out now sorry
doggy no don't do that and he says the
story is really you have to think about
it some curious what's gonna be jeez
says you probably could have died back
there I'm glad we haven't up yet
you know what's coming though we're
wearing a red sweater we probably should
change the sweater this is so
interesting though it's so nicely paced
I love it nut paste paste whatever you
understand me shut up
is that a helicopter that's a helicopter
oh
well that's a weird-looking helicopter
should I just keep running I think I
should just keep running oh oh
they're shooting me I'm dead aren't I
I think I died well I up told you
it was coming alright it's part of the
game to die alive maybe I can crouch or
something there's nothing to hide behind
is it maybe I just wasn't fast
what already died twice the car won't
come out unless I move look at this it's
like it knows they knew they knew I
would do this and I get shot if I run
back oh my god he's crawling that's
darkest this game is dog it's dude
they really know I think that's a good
way to know if it's a good game is that
the developer knows how you will think
maybe I should jump here and then hide
behind the fat make sense
it was more simple than than you'd think
okay we're fine so now we know even
though you're a little boy you can be
brutally murdered very nice so why are
these people killing us or hunting us
I don't know could this be like Nazi
Germany or some does this seem like
the cars a too modern other after us
again
oh my god go go go go go oh he's
tiny he's running after us oh my god
jump oh my god this is giving me goose
bumps
holy okay go go go jump oh they're
shooting the mist amazing oh my god I I
have goosebumps that was so thrilling
this is incredible they're shooting me I
gotta go down they got me
I had to stay underneath surface god
this is so cool okay how do I dive
that's going down just hold down okay I
don't think I have like that long breath
though oh there it is I just gotta have
to stay away from the light that's it
that's the key these guys are really out
to get me though I must have done
something bad and surely they would have
just given up
goddamn the dog scared man why they dead
pigs what what is up with this why would
there be dead pigs oh he looks at them
if you turn around yeah like oh wait
sorry he's kind of like
oh my god how's he doing
I don't know sorry I was just trying to
find clues and hints and what's
happening
it just seems like that kind of game
Aloha no matter what he just keeps going
the same direction
oh no not cornfields cornfields is never
good in any movie game or whatever oh
god I could have just opened it should I
close it wonder if I even can I can't
well doesn't look like good corn you
know they're gonna find me here John I'm
trying to keep I'm looking everywhere I
hear something
do you hear it what is that sound
oh no more outposts what are these
things what are they
hello guys what are they though are they
on my side
it seems scared of me they're gonna give
away my location what um
power plant what is this I don't know oh
my god has had more dead pigs what the
hell is happening here little piggies no
that's okay he's looking at this wall oh
there's a rope here bye guys I'll see
you on the other side I'm gonna go I got
to swing it and one if I can even jump
backwards here I can okay now we're in a
house okay there's a lever here very
suspiciously placed I feel like I have
to pull it no it won't work we have to
get the machinery first I'm targeted oh
man is it going alright we did it
now we pull the lever we're starting the
machinery oh god the pig the pig
machinery I'm sure
oh god what's going to come out of that
we got to get that convey about going
first I think but I can't get up let's
try walking less mother rhythm of it
this is the red the net yeah that's
nothing every time oh I hear our little
friends so you want to come in perhaps
pulling up hi guys you want to come in
there's no rain in here
hey they're following me I think chicken
oh Jesus
now they're not chicken but there's some
some kind of weird universe animal oh
god no don't make me kill them play dead
what are you gonna do with these
chickens they calling me oh no no I see
where that hole goes
no no they get sucked in okay they're
fine oh my heart my heart can't alright
so we're gonna have to run all the way
here is there a bit slow
come on guys come on guys the party over
here yi yi
they really like me yeah okay then we
run over here I'm gonna pull the lever
and they should get sucked in
yes
and oh my god haha
that is the strange puzzle but I love it
okay
we did it I didn't even know that's what
I was supposed to do alright lads
you want to come with me let's see if
you can bring us with this is one of
them dead
what is that movie
Hey
okay no they come back what the hell
stir hole-in-the-wall okay maybe I don't
have to do that then I'm sorry guys
I'm sorry alright let's keep going
we're outside now I'm gonna miss them I
named them all chicken one chicken -
chicken three chicken for all my god
more pigs what is with this game in dead
days
this is a amnesia sequel I think we have
to jump down the pigs that's why I took
a sip of coffee me that's
disgusting I don't think that's a
comfortable landing under my you bread I
can push this oh look at the pig ah
okay now we can climb up got it some
pluses holders simple some are a little
bit trickier wait what is this assassins
creed we're sneaking again why is dawn
coming we're sinking
I don't know I don't think we can make
it past you we can climb these okay cool
that's very cool but nice Jam
I wonder if the Sun is coming yet you
driving jump that's so cool
so detail wait is the tail moving it's a
maggot sir
I think it's maggots where you see it on
the other one as well what is happening
here dude I'm not a key
game is freaky man you never know all
right follow me buddy follow me for a
little piggy tap that ass G you like
that I can pull his tail
oh it's I was right it wasn't it's like
a slug me
maybe it's controlling it's still alive
I'm sorry buddy
poor thing did you know pigs are really
intelligent I found that out recently
and it made me feel like the worst
person ever
don't play with my emotions this game
gonna make me turn into a bit Terran or
some
can't you with that okay we're back so I
got a phone call come on piggy maybe I
need to climb on this thing that would
make sense sorry buddy
I know you're tired but I gotta do that
what the what the is happening
with this game oh that looked like it
hurt we need more people so these guys
got to open up for these guys so
interesting so they're using this to
control humans that's probably what I
broke free from I was probably being
used as well
needs more power maybe
push it back
so strange okay
I think now I can get myself out of here
I'm gonna come with me buddy
just your journey in here I'm sorry I'll
see ya
appreciate that was freaky as hell man
what is gonna happen what is going on
inside are they're referring to the
things in status dawn is coming very
pretty it's gorgeous
actually for a game so dark I don't know
you enjoying this I love this so far
this is amazing
there's more people being controlled I'm
not gonna walk in this probably get
some disease hepatitis what is
happening are they sleep are they
waiting to go to work no that's not it
I just thought I heard Yanni there's a
hook there how do I get up oh yeah cuz a
lot of times you look where you need to
go
that makes it down what's going on seem
like I'll I just have to push it to the
right then maybe then I'm not we're just
gonna have to see I'm sure that's not
just it okay we're climbing up what do
we have here let's do a little swing oh
I think I hear the chickens although I'm
not sure they are chickens they do sound
like it tonight
hey it's very night like the way you
control it oh my god
it's a little birds but I'm nice okay so
you see he's looking at the bollocks so
you kind of know sort of what you have
to do we have to get the box down how I
don't know the chickens come back and if
we scare them this way
there's definitely something about them
if they come back all right let's check
here to the right I will try and edit
like as long as possible and these only
if I really get stuck or things get
redundant which it tends to do with me
involved but I want you to have the
similar experience as I am having while
playing it although
if you are interested in the game do
pause wait for the game to come out and
buy it yourself because ain't nothing
like experience it yourself for the
first time okay that helpful let's try
it yeah that was it
how we just jump down here try not to
get kill this guy seems to have strong
legs drink a lot of milk notice no come
on it looked like the guy refused us to
walk in any other dimension maybe
there's a reason for it later
yeah I can literally can't see outside
of 2d space come on a guy
all right there it is okay ooh ooh place
is here why would you do that come on
that killed me didn't it whoopsie
all right I'm gonna have to end the
first episode they're really really if
you enjoy this leave a like and I will
upload one tomorrow another part I
promise thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you bros in the next
episode as always stay awesome rest oh
no I didn't do anything to disturb they
walked right into it
no that is disgusting
do I have to witness all this this is
part of myself